if you're looking for a quiet remote
family getaway look no further than the
newly renovated Overlook Hotel with our
famous garden maze and beautifully
appointed interiors there's a surprise
around every corner
our staff is hard at work to make you
feel welcome the Overlook Hotel come
stay with us forever and ever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you good evening good evening it's
wonderful to see you all here I'm Don
Hudson CEO of the Academy Museum of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences thank
you thank you it's it's my great
pleasure to welcome you here tonight and
to introduce tonight's talk because it's
about my favorite topic the new Academy
Museum of Motion Pictures and it's now
under construction on Wilshire Boulevard
in Los Angeles now I know that the
American film industry was actually born
right here in New York or I should say
the tri-state area across the river in
New Jersey but it grew up in New York
with respect to the filmmakers are who
are here tonight but then in the 1910s a
handful of pioneering filmmakers
migrated West to an obscure place called
Hollywood in search of better yes some
Californians we in search of better
weather better light and also eager to
put a few thousand miles between them
and mr. Edison's energetic patent
attorneys so after more than a century
of film production in Southern
California the Academy Museum will open
its doors in a city that has been I'm
scared to say this and remains the world
capital of filmmaking at the academy we
felt that the prominence of our
organization of our members of our
extraordinary collections and the
crucial importance of Los Angeles give
us a special responsibility and we are
fulfilling that responsibility with this
new Academy Museum and now the public
will file of this audience god bless you
oh great you are ready for this thank
you
the public will finally have a place to
see the work that the Academy does
year-round beyond the Oscars for decades
so first let me call to the stage one of
the world's outstanding museum
professionals and I don't know anyone
who knows as much about art contemporary
art contemporary artists the history of
film the history of film in all genres
because thank God he's not a movie snob
he served as a top curator in at MOCA in
Los Angeles the director of the Museum
of Modern Art in Oxford England he was
led the Hirshhorn Museum
before coming to Los Angeles and please
welcome the director of the Academy
Museum of Motion Pictures Carrie Brauer
and next I want to introduce a man who
is no stranger to this building he's the
one who designed it he's one of the
greatest architects of all time and my
personal favorite from Genoa Italy
please welcome Renzo Piano
I'm so great this is so great we've got
nothing but rock stars tonight our
moderator is a member of the Board of
Governors of the Academy you can imagine
how much more fun the board meetings are
she's hosted four Academy Awards she's
won an Oscar herself she's also one of
the rare people who has achieved
II got status an Emmy Grammy I know an
Oscar and a Tony the Grand Slam of
awards all this and she's a native New
Yorker please welcome Whoopi Goldberg
so welcome everybody they were very
specific and telling us to make sure we
picked up our mics and didn't sit on
them so I'm glad to see we listened so
let's talk about this museum which
people have been talking about since
really the inception of film you know
they because you know everything has a
museum but the Academy and I no one can
tell me why so I wonder if you can tell
me why now
well yeah not quite since the inception
of film but pretty close to the
beginning no in 1929 Douglas Fairbanks
Mary Pickford who started the Academy
did say that they thought there should
be a library devoted to cinema and that
there had been enough history of the
medium and it was such a great art form
that it deserved to have a museum and so
plans should be put into the works for
the creation of a museum so 9 it's not
only 90 years later we will open the
museum right on time for for Mary
Pickford and Douglas Fairbanks they're
no longer with us but we're gonna open
it anyway now I don't know why it took
so long
you know Los Angeles started film museum
several times and every time not just
the Academy but the city to County and
every time they would start it something
would happen you know it was like maybe
they were too busy making movies to
actually have a museum but I think it
usually was something more bizarre than
that like at one point in 1964 I think
it was they actually broke ground on a
museum the county did I don't know if
you know this runs off but and and one
guy wouldn't sell his house so they had
to pull out and it became a political
thing so something always happened and
but now finally I think we've done it
Wow we're close well you think they
would have given the guy apart that's
actually a good point
it was the county though so all right
and can you um tell me and so is it hard
to create this museum in the midst of
the the moviemaking capital it's always
hard to make a museum no not really
because we have the building that is a
piece of history in Los Angeles when we
started that job you know I was told
this building the may company right on
the corner between we shop over in
Fairfax is a piece of history
it was built in 39 I said well I was
made in 37 so I'm more historical back
you know we started very well I mean I
can understand okay and it's always good
when you have something to grab on you
know it's not true that the total
freedom is better so I was we were quite
pleased I should have that piece there
except that we can fit a movie theater
of 1000 seats in that building so that's
it is why then we had that building but
I know in some way it came it came quite
you know if you look at the section that
drawing there you understand we have a
you know the kind of flow between the
two building one on the right is is the
historical is a department store right
now become more like a factory for movie
history you know that and then we have
bridges and we have this movie theater
this bit like a spaceship ready to take
off you know that is by the way what
cinema is about breaking off so it's not
really more difficult than you you know
what what is it more difficult is to
accept the world museum for me because a
long time ago in the seventies when I
was young
boy together with another bad boy that
was Richard Rogers we made the south
Pompidou in Paris and that was the
moment when we decided that the word
museum was almost a bad word you know
because we they didn't was that a
building for culture should be open
accessible not intimidating so museum
are normally intimidating so that was
the moment when we started this idea
that culture building museum should be
open accessible
non-intimidating creating the sense of
curiosity but in reality when you talk
about movie and a cinema you understand
that even having something like a museum
that is about duration is about
longevity is about time right time and
that is not bad at all it's time maybe
in twenty nine nineteen it was a bit too
early but now it's the time I like that
well I noticed that there is a
similarity you like open you like to
make things open this when this is not
here you have this space looking towards
where the traffic is and you sort of
feel that that it's there's big breaths
in there and I noticed the same thing in
the in the drawings for the museum why
was it important to make it feel like
you could breathe in there well you know
making I could touch it's not that far
away from making movie you know it's
always about sequence it's a different
kind of sequence in the cinema use you
sit and the movie moves in architecture
you don't sit you move right you stand
but the idea on this building yeah
actually we are entering the building
from north the side but you see the
sequence of different plane multiple
plane exactly like you are sitting there
you see true see the gun and then you
see the lobby then you see traffic and
and the bus terminal this idea of a
sequence is very important and the
entire building is conceived not just
this picture but the entire building is
conceived like a sequence between light
and shadow you know this and this is by
the way what cinema does it's a sequence
in time in Natchitoches is a sequence II
movement and I think that what's amazing
about this is with Renzo just brought up
the term Museum and we like the term
museum because you know it's it's time
for a Museum of film but a museum of
film is a very strange kind of hybrid
thing it's about the art it's about the
science it's about all kinds of things
that film art all the different art
forms that come together to make a movie
and I think you have to attack it in a
different way than a regular museum you
have to do it on a multiplicity of
levels the first one and the most
important is actually a great movie
theater and in that movie theater you
need to be able to show 16 millimeter
and 35 millimeter 70 laser projection
and and we're even equipped in the large
theater the one you see there with
nitrate so we can see prints that were
actually made in the 30s or 40s so
that's that's actually the key and the
movie theater is is like a bit of the
spaceship right you you climb into it
and it takes you elsewhere it takes you
to other places other lands far away in
the future in the past so that's that's
the anchor and then then you need
exhibitions but exhibition with film is
it like an exhibition with art you hang
the art on the wall that's kind of like
it was meant to be seen but film wasn't
necessarily meant to be walked through
in that way as Renzo said it sort you
sort of sit still and it walks around
you but we're gonna do exhibitions as
well and that's where we can really
learn go behind the scenes in these sort
of immersive environments that you know
have instil a film installations
multiple screens sound architectural
installations production design and
really learn how films were actually
made so and then an Education Center
will be there this amazing Terrace which
overlooks the Hollywood Hills the views
of the Hollywood Hills and all kinds of
things that will be in this place I
think we couldn't understand cinema in
its its full-blown sense without all of
these things actually you know the it's
called the Academy the Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences and so when you go to
at least one as a kid when I went to the
movie in a very interesting way you came
in the first thing you saw outside were
flashes of what you would see inside Co
you had the pictures and you have the
marquees and then you went in and then
they had some more information about the
film and so you got your anticipation up
so that by the time you got in there and
sat down and got your popcorn and
jujubes you were yeah jujubes you were
ready to be taken wherever you were
going to go now when I think of movies
and from 1960s and how movies are done
now that's where for me all the sciences
come in I don't think people ever call
the Academy as it should be called
because you can't have one without the
other innovation continues to happen can
you talk a little bit about how you're
going to tie that in to the museum yeah
actually the the main exhibition which
will be on floors two and three will
will not be a straightforward history of
cinema but it will actually be taken
from the point of view of the filmmaker
it's a history of filmmaking and of
course there's a lot of history of films
but we're starting back in the 19th
century we sort of take you back in time
you go backwards first then you start a
march forward watching the evolution of
cinema develop and all the great
wondrous things it's a little bit like a
magician you know that magician shows
his magic and we want it to be magical
in the spaces we want it to be cinematic
but not so much so that you disappear
completely into the dream so you're
still part way awake to be able to
understand
and the art and science then that came
together to create you know the great
artworks of the 20th century in cinema
so when I went to the site I was kind of
surprised I took a tour with you Carrie
last month let's can we talk a little
bit about the buildings that are part of
the campus the museum campus and the
inspiration for the design
don't rush for rent
what can I say
what can I say well the first thing is
that I have to say that the first time I
went there a long time ago
designing the the County Museum the like
that like my Billy those building it I
counted in the street
few people by our you know by a half an
hour you know you stay there nowadays
use you have more people working this
and that's the funny new Los Angeles is
becoming a pedestrian city it slowly
very slowly but it is becoming a Podesta
and and you know the big things and they
are building they're building a new
subway there will have a new subway and
the idea to have a campus in the middle
of the city in the middle of the mess
and for me math is not that bad you know
it's like welcome yeah it's part of life
and all that so it's a quite challenging
and by the way you know I I was also I
wanted to say something about this idea
of museum because I said before for me
Museum is something that feel like I
bought something consolidated and finish
but this is what is making this
challenge especially complicated because
it's a is it not cinema that is the only
contemporary art together with the close
friend photography of course the only
but it's in the same time worth of kind
of historical study today because it's
one century so we have history but at
the same time is art in science and the
science I keep changing and so it's
still moving still changing yeah so you
are making a Museum of something that
still change and you know thanks God
thanks God
I I just will say this now perhaps you
want to check and make sure your phones
are off it happens I forget to and I
don't know if you should be shooting
this okay we go I what I want trying to
say that science mean that cinema is it
feed is even contaminated in some way in
the good science yeah by invention by
reality by new things and this is what
is making this adventure so mad so
incredible because it's about two things
that look almost contradiction of
history and future invention but they
are not they're not so in some way
that's why this building is made of two
pieces in some ways like a flood between
the old and the new the flood between a
building that is a piece of history
itself and and a and the sphere and the
sphere is the spaceship ready to take
off and and this is some way in some way
it's a museum but it's also factory yeah
laboratory for the future of cinema and
maybe I should add to that that's
exactly right and I should add to it
that the exhibition's won't be just
about the past though also be about the
present in the future and we actually
have a space carved out in the museum
Renzo helped us find a space in which we
could actually cut through the centre of
the museum it's right in the heart of
the museum actually and create a
double-height space that's 34 feet tall
and that will become a space primarily
used for for lack of a better term
expanded cinema type projects multi
screen multiple screen installations or
interactive projects maybe ones using
virtual reality or
augmented reality and so we want to push
the envelope on that and actually help
become kind of a platform to Commission
things for the future so so well we hope
to take cinema into its next phase and
because in a way you know they're all
worried about cinema cinema dying you
know it's told we've been told us dying
numerous times but it's really expanding
into all these other areas you know it's
kind of interesting because when you
talk about the history of cinema you
know there are so many facets to it and
it's fluid its ever-changing it's always
going to be I hear people talking about
Oh movies you're done
no because the experience that you get
the collective experience that you get
in a movie house watching something on a
huge screen is vastly different than
when you're watching it at home you know
you're surrounded by others who are
going through the same experience so now
in thinking that way and thinking about
really the past will the museum be able
to encompass the the positive history
and the rough history that they also
encompass in terms of you know removing
people or not allowing people to
participate or painting people up you
know because there was this idea that
you couldn't have real Asian people
unless they were in a second a third
area part we were talking about Luise
Rainer in the Good Earth you know as
opposed to Anna May Wong who went up for
the part and then didn't get it yeah and
you know that that's stories that we
those are the stories we do want to tell
though that's just as much a part of the
story of the studio system as as other
stories and we also want to tell the
stories about the fact that when the
power started to become you know started
to gather together in mass out in in
Hollywood with with the Douglas
Fairbanks Mary Pickford's
Chaplin's DW Griffith's they you know
it's SOP dimille's all of that and the
moguls then came to be there's another
story to be told because people were
being left out of that as great as that
was there were other film makers around
the country and tiny studios scattered
all over this country that made films
called race films and it was every genre
yeah I mean it was it was it was the
cowboy movie yeah
the Western it was as gangster films it
was adventure films and but they all
start african-americans and people don't
know that history and that's one
actually where we're we're gonna be
telling at the museum as well well I
also wanted to mention by the way
because we got into this about the idea
of sitting with people to watch movies
the interesting thing is it's it's all
come full circle because the very
beginning of of the cinema is pretty
much a beginning of watching things
individually looking into the
Kinetoscope looking at the stereoscope
you know and the praxinoscope you know
where very few people could see it at
once usually just one and so we kind of
come all the way back to that now with
your iPhone so you know it's it it
evolves and yet echoes itself at the
same time I always enjoyed to say
something opposite to what
[Laughter]
but no I just it's not opposite I just
want to add one thing watching a movie
in in a movie theater is about
conviviality and it's about sharing the
same enjoyment it's about staying
together that's a reason wine is
something magic in human being to be
together and to share the same values
and this is something that will never
disappear you know it's the same thing
with music web design so many concert
all when you are in the concert hall and
you are 1,000 people 1,500 people
listening to the same music of course we
enjoy the music but you also enjoy being
together with other people join the same
music and this is what we call it
conviviality
that's your vanity that's a sense of
humanities is the essence of humanism
and evening and this apply also to the
cinema of course everybody can enjoy
looking at moving in the screen it
doesn't matter it's not about the size
of the screen you may be very vision to
have any man screen on but you are just
yourself you are not together with other
people join the same thing you know all
this is that is one of the reason why
making those buildings called museum
call whatever house of cinema call as
you like but one of the magic thing is
that you do place where people meet and
they stay together right and they share
the same values and this this is the
beginning of something that I call
simple civic civic pride and civic is
silica behavior I agree when you talk
about the museum how will look a past
present and future when you're talking
about cinema how will people who are
seeing this museum in 40 years
still have a flavor for what we're going
to see when you when it opens next year
is it is it being built so that
it can continue to physically evolve as
well yes I hope so you know it's funny
as we've been putting this museum
together one of the things that has come
up occasionally from from people is that
we shouldn't show silent film because no
one remembers oh yeah I mean I get that
from from a lot of people why do what is
the reason for showing silent film
because no one remembers those people
what is the reason for having a von
Sternberg movie because no one remembers
my Lena Dietrich and and it should
really be about today so you know and my
answer is well if they're starting to
forget that's all the more reason for
the museum and that we need to preserve
that legacy so I think that we should
you also have the flexibility that 40
years from now what we're doing today
will become part of that museum as well
yeah and and that's one of the one of
the things that Renzo and I talked about
at the very beginning was having
flexible gallery space so that we could
change that space in any way that it
needed to be changed and not be locked
into one system and Renzo was was more
than happy to give us that I think this
story of the time duration is very
important what is good about museum and
I start to love museum at this point in
time is because they are about duration
I said before and this is very important
is duration in the sense in many sense
first physically speaking you don't make
a building for 50 years or hundred years
you may be building for a few thousand
years
well I'm not joking I come from a
country where it's quite normal to see a
building that is 2,000 year old
yeah what is wrong about that so
duration is also in that sense
physically but the only one is is
metaphorical position
I mean cinema start to to deserve an
attitude well you know it's it's not
really just something
is also something that as value that are
set up yeah
again when I'm Italian so every time I
think about the new realism in Italy for
example after the war that's something
that for me is a kind of fundamental
piece but so many so many things so me
making museum that's why making museum
is not it's not bad of course at one
condition that we understand that should
be not the place intimidating yeah it
should be place where people can feel
easy to come and also where they
discover everything including the future
and that's why I believe that I don't
know I will be not there probably but in
one other year somebody may come there
and do the same to the same movie
theater that will probably work in a
completely different way but still it
will fly on the street applause and it
will be still ready to take off for
Germany I mean do you think that that
the museum will have space for people to
at some point when we are able to really
hone in on virtual reality will we be
able to walk on to the set of who's
afraid
no not Who's Afraid of Virginia but
whatever happened to be sorry whatever
happened to Baby Jane you know or be
able to sit and watch an actor prepare
for a role that happened you know a
hundred years prior because do you think
it's important for people to understand
how this actually how how this actually
works because most people I don't think
know what goes into why it takes five
hundred million people to make a movie I
mean that that's what that's one of the
the major points of doing the museum is
to really show what it takes to get a
movie made and you know we've actually
discussed how at the beginning it was
one person with a camera
and and now the credits roll in it's as
you say five 500 people but each one of
those individuals has a real role at a
real job to do and one of the things
with the Academy the Academy is divided
up into all these different branches
right and that we decided early on
that's not how we wanted to do the
museum because it kept the branches
separate and really when they're on the
set and they're really working on a film
everyone's communicating everyone's
talking you have to talk to one another
and so what we wanted to show was how
these branches came together to actually
work together to to create a film and so
that's one of the reasons we want to
take it from that perspective one of the
things that we can do because it's the
Academy probably better than any other
film museum could do is that we can
actually also have incredible public
programs by the actual makers of these
films you know whether it's someone from
Steven Spielberg you know or Martin
Scorsese down you know to say a costume
designer or the production designer or
the makeup artist and people can
actually hear from them personally how
these films got made so they'll hear
directly from the filmmakers and that's
with the networking system of the
Academy that's one of the things we can
really bring to this museum or really
it's almost like a center or like a hub
for people to come all the film lovers
in Los Angeles and all over the nation
internationally who loves cinema to see
it in different ways either on the big
the big silver screen in an exhibition
in a public program and to discuss it
and be there and communicate with one
another so Rennes was very right it'll
be an international center because it's
not just American cinema that we're
talking about when we go into this
museum is that right no it's not and
it's not just about Hollywood it's it is
about international cinema yes our
cinema will evolve of course but one
thing's for sure it will be forever up
to tell stories and it doesn't matter
what is the instrument of telling the
story but what count what matter is the
story right it's the motion that you are
able to do and this is something by the
way in in a different way but it's also
a catastrophe that is also telling
stories when you make it breathing like
this it's about so nobody can say but
one thing that will remain forever is
the fact that you need a house for those
poor things house a place where things
can be seen and where you meet other
people that love the same thing and this
is something that is essential and as
you build this are you because when you
think about all of the sciences that go
in so we're talking about things like
sound and lighting you are in you know
one of the mecca's where some of the
best in the business are are they going
to be able to come in and assist you in
making sure the lighting is right for
this or making sure that the sound in
the room is that or all the things that
go into this yes we've been very lucky
to been very lucky to have a number of
individuals you know with the academy
you know with the governors of the
academy outside of the governor's to
with people in the industry who have
already come and actually worked with us
to to help us figure out how we might do
a certain room the sound is a good is a
good example of that and it's very
important to hear all those ideas out
because there's an incredible you know
creativity from those individuals and
it's a new experience for me you know
working with them I mean with the main
individual that we're working with is a
production designer by the name of Rick
Carter who has he won an Oscar for
avatar and also for Lincoln and he's a
wonderful individual a real sort of
philosopher about about film and and how
things should get put together and it's
been a learning experience for him too
because that I
submission slightly different than
production design so working together
we've been trying to come up with new
ways of actually showing film in in the
gallery spaces and so it's not just a
bunch of objects although objects will
be there and it's not just a bunch of
film clips but it's the kind of
immersive feeling that you'll have as
you go through so yes we've been working
closely with a number of filmmakers and
it's been a lot of I want to read
something I know that you're very very
and worried about practical things I
know because I've been watching of
course of course including a vast room
and all those things but you know they
and you are right you are right building
is a machine a building is a machine and
of course this building will be much you
can they were I can I have the picture
of the section can you show that section
no not that one the the spine the spine
not the spine the spine as a shadow the
Chinese shadow yeah well look at that
this is what you see when you are in
anime company building this is the place
of shadow and you look to the sphere to
the movie theater this is what you see
you this is the diagram of people moving
in in the building right and that's why
I'm talking about machine of course
those live elevator those escalator
diamond they must work right it must
work for sure but the reason why I'm
showing this is because they must work
but in the same time this is what makes
architecture quite interesting it's not
just about things working it's not just
technology but it's also the fact that
this is actually cinema because in the
normal day in the normal Saturday
afternoon here you will have a 1000
people moving up and down you have
people because everybody in the building
will move on that on that area so they
will take escalator they will take the
stair they will move up and down with so
it's a kind of living diagram it's
actually cinema
it's a cinema actually I was saying to
carry
joking that I hope people will sit there
other people moving around you know
because because the this is the reason
why I could touch in some way also tell
Esther and the building is always a
combination of technology machine things
that work and and and and the dream and
and and you know then then inspiration
and beauty in some way because this is
also about beauty and and in fact that
this building is about cinema and you
must feel that is about cinema is about
movement so the the contrast of light
and dark is important to you with this
building yes well that's the first thing
we've been discussing with the filmmaker
when we start there remember Steven
Spielberg telling me the first time we
met I mean so it's everything is about
sequence between light and shadow and
back again so yes it's true the working
on the light is fundamental and
especially in this because we are
looking not and we are looking to the
light and so the people moving will be
like it's shining the shadow so in some
way the light is beyond so it's it's
it's always working on those it's not
just light and shadow it's also
compression expansion is also silence
and and an action it's it's about many
men right but this is what the sequence
mean by the way the sequence is also
what matter in there music music we have
the same thing we have a sequence and
Anaka touch is the same thing
so this is a really long question Karen
I know for my recent visit to the museum
that you have some amazing objects like
the Aries 1b lunar lander the only
remaining model from Kubrick's 2001
Space Odyssey animatronics from films
like Terminator 2 an American Werewolf
in London and of course the ruby
slippers from The Wizard of Oz and the
library has an insanely amazing
collection of photographs production and
costume design drawing scripts and
posters including a couple that I
brought to y'all yeah because I think
it's important I think it's important so
but can you tell us a bit more about the
collection and what visitors can expect
to see yeah did the answer is yes we do
have all those things we've been you
know the the Academy had already a
library you know that was started a long
time ago the library is unbelievably
packed full of amazing materials and it
includes I think it's over 12 million
photographs at the moment and 55,000
screenplays and posters and they're
annotated screenplays too so if you want
to if you want to see what Fred cinnamon
was thinking when he shot High Noon you
can read it right in you know his notes
or Gregory pecks performance in To Kill
a Mockingbird the notes are right there
in the screenplay
great posters and more thanks to you and
so so it's a wonderful collection of
works on paper basically then the Film
Archive has an amazing collection of
films a hundred thousand different
titles in in their collection but what
the Academy didn't do over the years so
much was collect three-dimensional
objects so there were a few things but
not much so we've been trying to over
the last three or four years
build that collection of props and
artifacts and things of this nature some
of the things that you just mentioned
you've been lucky enough to get ahold of
save the ruby slippers you know and the
close-up pair was used in the close-ups
so and and and Kubrick mentioning the
lunar lander you never know what this
stuff's gonna turn up it turned up in
someone's garden shed in in England and
and Kubrick had all the the models
destroyed because he didn't want them
appearing in other films and
particularly sequels to 2001 and and but
one of them got away and we did have
Douglas Trumbull come look at it and it
is the real one and so we were able to
get our hands on that so we're building
a collection but as I say you know the
objects are fantastic and when they're
from really well-known films they have a
kind of aura about them they do become a
kind of relic in a way which is rather
wonderful but you know but I think when
one is learning about the cinema it has
to be more than just objects and I think
too many film museums around the world
are just crammed with objects and they
don't bring those objects back to life
and to do that I think you've got to
reintroduce the Moving Image in a big
way in into the exhibitions and into the
museum not just in the in the theatres
which of course it will be there but but
actually in the gallery spaces
themselves and you have to do that in a
very cinematic way and I actually come
out of the art world so even though I've
led a very schizophrenic life you know
doing film exhibitions in the art world
but from contemporary artists actually
learned how one can be creative with
screens for example where you can have a
series of screens you know each with a
montage on it so you have montages
against montages in rooms and you can
say things not just in a linear fashion
but in space as well as you walk through
so it'll be a combination of those
things as you move through
the museum so I'm gonna pose this
question to the two of you what
possessed you to say yes when they said
do you want to do this why did you say
yes what is it a love of cinema what
what made you think yeah I want to I
want to I want to do this for me it's
essential that possess
first essential to have pedestrian of
course because we are but there are
these to make the ground floor totally
porous and totally open accessible so
they di that action look at it this is
the ground floor and as you know this
was a department store a very famous one
everybody innocently know this the may
company so we didn't demolish the
building that is because it's a part of
the history but also it's very very
solid building and we just made this
space that is so Janelle's it look like
a factory look totally flexible and the
idea and that this floor that is the
first floor the ground floor it's
totally open is three people come from
which I prefer they come but it will be
not free when you go up but you know on
this level is free you have a restaurant
we have activity in like like art or
cinema and we have all those things and
the everything start from the idea that
the ground floor is a part of the city
it is is that the building in this case
doesn't fly because we cannot fly but
you know this is one of my constant idea
I mean even in in New York the new
Whitney is is a flying vessel and and
and we have and we have a space
underneath because because this is what
you have to do because you have to give
back to the city what you take the city
give you a piece of land and you give
back so you're sitting at home nice
glass of vino
talking to your lovely wife and the
phone rings and somebody says design the
new Academy Museum for us here in Los
Angeles do you say of course I've always
wanted to do that or do you say prego
what made you say yes it is a funny
story first you never say yes because
you are very busy in doing something
else so normally the answer is oh well
I'm not sure I know that but then then
then you start to think about and you
know what happened that as an architect
sometime if you're in the right moment
in the right place you don't change the
world for sure the world doesn't change
is not changing because of the architect
but the work the word change the moment
when you have a shift in the world and
then as an actor you are there to build
that change to give me a bit expression
to that change that's what you do so
after saying no first time then you
think better you say wait a second but
this is this is one of the shift of the
of the of them of them of the culture
because this is the moment when a a
great piece of history in cinema become
mature enough to become you know to be
invisible and become a place where you
go and know that so you start to think
about that and this is what happened
when you are called to make a public
building and you know even this building
where we are it's not public but it's
part of Times Square as part of this and
it's all and in some way that's the
reason why you can see through and you
see the traffic on the 8th Avenue and
you see then and then the bus terminal
because because making public building
is
putting the city places of civic life
and this is the beginning of something
that make a lot of sense because cities
are still great invention but they need
those things to be better place to live
so you know every time you sit and
somebody ask you some things to make
complicated difficult like this one
because you don't even know how to call
it
you call museum or you call house or you
can factor it doesn't matter but you you
say yes because it's about making place
for people to stay together to stay
together end to end and to mix
experience and and in those buildings
and finally some miracle happen the
diversity is no more a problem
diversity become a value so you know
there's something miraculous happening
so every time you understand that this
may happen then you say yes I'll ask you
the same question you sitting around you
know looking out on the vast horizon
behind your house
what a glass window and somebody calls
you and says hey we really need somebody
that was Don Hudson yeah why did you say
yes well what such a good answer I can't
top that but you know I'm from Los
Angeles and when I was growing up there
I could never understand why there
wasn't a film museum there and it was
such a great Center for the making of
movies and I've always loved film and
with one degree in in art history and
one degree in in film history and
exhibitions that I had done you know
when someone asks you to do a film
museum in your hometown that has needed
a film museum I think for decades
there's no way I could say no to that
and it was sort of like a dream job to
be honest with you so I said yes and
this building comes alive and people
will come and see it all kinds of folks
people who are interested in in
different aspects of film whether it's
in front of the camera or behind the
camera will there be residences where
you have director that's in residence
for a week giving master classes will
you will will it become not just this
building but this not just this living
building because we now know that it's
it's it's cinema and it's moving all
over but inside will people be able to
come and absorb from lots of different
groups or per views will we be able to
do that yes you know I I think that's
the most important thing in in a way and
Renzo's designed a building for us which
allows us to do so many different things
in it from education center you know
to enormous public programs in the
thousand-seat theater to more intimate
screenings in the 288 seat theater which
is on the lower level anything all May
company building by the way I think we
we failed to mention that the may
company building which is now known as
the Saban building after a major gift is
it was built in 1939 as you say two
years but it's a great year for motion
pictures right so I think it was meant
to be all the vectors coming together so
so I think what the surprise is going to
be when you come to the museum that
you're going to see cinema in so many
different forms in so many different
ways and over such a long period of time
and you know the the history of film is
extremely complex and you know it's it's
only about the same history as modern
art right it's about the same time
period and and yet it almost feels to me
like like the the history of film is
much more layered and complex than the
history of modern art per se and trying
to tell that story is is a challenge but
you have to tell it in all kinds of
different ways from from temporary shows
permanent shows specially designed
projects commissions public programs
with great filmmakers and at an
education center for young people to
give them their first taste of what it's
like to be creative with the moving
image Andrus ound and and from there
hope that they understand that they too
can move on to be filmmakers maybe go to
UCLA or USC or NYU or learn hair and
makeup because the makeup you know the
things that happen in terms of what
happens on a movie set you know it's
hair and makeup and it's wardrobe
you know it's knowing why something
hand-sewn by you know
a great wardrobe mistress is heaven why
people often take take clothes home
because sometimes they're better made
than a lot of what you can buy but to
have people understand that they're that
you need all of these things and to
understand like a costume designer might
actually make four or five six different
versions of the same outfit and you know
the great story is like Lawrence of
Arabia right where they made numerous
versions you know of the white robes and
as the movie progresses and things get
darker the robe actually they they wore
the fabric and they wore it down and
actually changed the fabric by the end
of it so that it didn't look as white
and lovely it's like I'm getting you
know he starts out in this suit and and
suddenly in the middle he's in you know
linen you know and you're thinking okay
that is a big deal to see how would you
see how it's done the transition but so
much so much of the filmmaking the arts
and filmmaking are invisible to us as we
watch the film right and so one of the
things you have to do is to bring that
you know make that invisible art visible
to people so they understand it better I
think I try to answer to this question
what can you bring on okay you go there
this is a constant preoccupation of
somebody making a creative work doesn't
matter if you are writer you write a
book if you want filmmaking what if
you're architecting make building what
can people bring back on and I think for
me the answer is that people will bring
on something only if there is a poetry
there if there is a beauty and poetry
it's not something
strange it's fundamental it's about it's
the emotional way you can submit
something and then you bring back on and
you know this is something they say it's
also maybe coming from the fact that I'm
Italian and you know and in in my
country but not just in my country in
all the country of Medina increase
everywhere the concept of beautiful
beauty is not just cosmetic it's not
husband it's not frivolous at all
beauty is a very profound concept it's
very profound it's very much about
beautiful and good and good coming
together and this is screamin important
that when you go there and I hope this
will happen it will happen I'm sure it
will happen people will go to that
building or to that place to that
institution they will amel they will
swim in those elements and probably they
will also be motion emotional about the
space I hope I hope but they they what
they bring back is something mysterious
and beautiful that is is a political
emotion is poetry I think this is and
and this is also part of the of the
reason why museum is is a special place
it's not just a museum publish because
because it is about something that
remain inside this is also true for a
movie even though you know very well
yourself
a movie gives something normally not
more than three or four things you know
that's already a lot but this is only if
beauty poetry is there because then it
comes inside and remain a little bit
about beauty in poetry because when I
think of all of the movie houses the
visual of these movie palaces that
they're older than my time but I've seen
all these amazing pictures and pictures
of what people who will work
in these movie houses you know they wore
uniforms and there was a whole there was
a whole piece that sort of happened when
you went to the movie theater as I think
I was telling you my mom explained to me
that she was dropped off you know at
9:00 in the morning and nobody saw those
kids until four o'clock because they
were in the theater they were watching
the you know the cereal and then the
movie but going into these movie palaces
was kind of a big deal and will we will
people be able to get information on
that kind of architecture and why they
were built that way or why people talked
about building the cinemas that way
because I don't we don't see a lot of
stunningly beautiful you know places
where you going and you think oh um this
is a palace I'm sitting in a palace you
know I'm I am somebody in this palace
will we get a feel of what the why of
that as well yes actually it you know I
think that's so important because it's
you know the the way the exhibitors you
know showed these films is is very much
a part of the history as much as the
films themselves and actually on the
lower level near where the 288 seat
theater is the the Ted Mann theater
there's an exhibition space down there
in which we're planning to show that
very thing we're planning to actually
show a lot about exhibitors about the
movie theatres about the concession
stands about the wonderful way that
movies were presented and it's very
interesting to you know pick up where
Renzo was saying because I think you
know the movie palace the way they used
to be you know in the 20s the 30s they
were telling you then that this is a
great art form that you're you're
entering something very special you know
whatever the movie was whether it was a
comedy or it was a Citizen Kane it was
it was something that was
very special and that was very much
about the 20th century 21st century but
but back then and and they were lending
a kind of aura of art to it because it
was often rejected as not art it still
is very often but it was in my view you
know probably the greatest art form of
the 20th century and I think it still is
the greatest art form it's just changing
and morphing into into other things so I
think it's really important to see how
we watched movies and how they it that
changed over the years from small little
storefronts that had them at the very
beginning Penny arcade's small theatres
and then building the grand movie
palaces you know because ultimately it's
this is the poetry in a way - that
you're talking about because the movie
theater is really when you think about
it it's a giant camera it's the it's
just the opposite or where the camera
actually is recording light coming from
the outside the movie theater is
projecting a cone of white light on the
inside and this other world that appears
this otherworldly light appears on the
screen and you go into a half state of
dreaming you're you're partially asleep
and partially awake it's a it's a
fabulous oh that's a poetic I have no
idea why beauty and dignity is no more
an essential part of our lives I don't
know why it's a sad sorry I don't know
but I'm doing my best to get away from
there and
it's a little drop at the top but it's
fundamental because beauty is and this
kind of beauty dignity is also about the
and civic pride its Association because
it's not a static it's not about free
quality something that is essential in
in a human in human beings and but you
are right it's sometime I really want
the why is no more so important because
it's a it's beautiful it's also dignity
dignity is is the pride right to be to
be part of something and you know and
and by the way what we are trying to do
yeah III I hope we will succeed I'm
pretty sure we will succeed we are doing
a plaint of things that are in some way
useless here
and I wore I use the word useless
because people believe that sometime
beauty is useless it's not something but
it's important by example the top of
this building can I have the top picture
on the terrace no no the one watching
out watching not watching olliewood this
one this is the terrace of the building
it's a total useless I can say because
but it's just the pleasure to come up
above the movie theater and then you
look to Los Angeles to the north so you
are not blinded by the Sun and you and
because of Santa is low long by the way
on the right here you can see olive wood
because it's there so so you realized
suddenly that you are not somewhere else
you are there right in Los Angeles but
those sort of things I think that you
have to do because they remind you that
beauty is a constant aspiration of human
being and we keep forgetting that
and what's important about this Terrace
- I think is you travel through the
museum and you get to the top and you
look out over and you Los Angeles and
Hollywood in the in the distance and you
know this museum is is not just because
of the film industry in Hollywood it's
also tied in with the history of Los
Angeles right as well so it's an
important museum for Los Angeles and you
know I don't want to give too much away
but we will have an app that works with
right things and when you're up on this
level you will be able to use the app to
look out to Hollywood right see laid out
spread out in front of you and you'll
you'll actually travel back in time and
you'll go back to the Hollywood of the
past and see what it was like when the
first movie studio and then travel
forward as it evolves over time and not
just not just the movies but also that's
Angeles itself and we can keep building
right well don't forget you know the
that New York
we are also here because you know a lot
of this started in Jersey so orange I
think it's probably it's not going to
happen in the next couple of years okay
but I think we should put in for an
extension so that people recognize that
Hollywood while people think it's in one
place Hollywood is in many places it's
Hollywood sort of this larger concept
it's a concept as was this conversation
thank you for coming
[Applause]